grand montréal ce matin le prix de
l'essence dépasse le cap symbolique des
2 $ le litre je trouve ça exagéré
c'est incroyable
les prix à la pompe tourne autour des 2
$ à montréal québec et saint jean terre
neuve c'est bon couvert qui trône au
sommet de la liste à deux dollars 16 le
litre aux antipodes des djeun un peu
plus d'un dollar 60 les automobilistes
canadiens devront se serrer la ceinture
d'un océan à l'autre ce trop cher mais
je sais pas leur région la raison le
baril de pétrole se maintient à plus de
100 dollars propulsé par la guerre en
ukraine et la perspective d'un embargo
européen sur le pétrole russe c'est très
élevé s'élever stable donc ça passe dans
la facture immédiatement
constants selon les experts au moins
pour quelques mois pas moins l'avis que
c'est tout ça va favoriser la vente de
véhicules électriques ça va nous faire
réfléchir sur les modes de transport
donc ça va permettre peut-être d'amour
ce d'accélérer la transition vers des
modes de transport moins énergivore
l'essence à fort prix nourrit l'espoir
d'une transition énergétique accéléré
ménard y est pour freiner l'inflation
galopante je pense qu'il faut continuer
de remettre l'argent dans le
portefeuille des québécois parce que
effectivement l'inflation est à un
niveau élevé les mois de juin juillet ou
ne feront pas de cadeaux aux vacanciers
qui verront leur budget amputé à moins
de s'adapter il faut s'attendre serrer
sa ceinture tout l'été et à envisager
des plans de vacances qui sont moins
énergivores parce que c'est certain
qu'il ya un très gros risque que le
conflit en ukraine perdure comment je
fais localement pas de pot 2
même avec la levée des voyages
internationaux les vacances de proximité
plus abordables pourraient avoir la cote
encore une fois cet été ici jean
philippe use radio canada montréal